hi guys how you doing today
please help me out here man it's been a
long two days how you guys doing today
hey thank you cool
um so uh again it's interesting um i'm
still getting used to seeing my name as
the cio of barclaycard my daughter
actually gave me another title and the
way i usually introduce myself is um i'm
the head of the thundering herd of nerd
a barclay card
and she makes sure she tells everybody
that's my job role
what i want to do today is i'm actually
going to
tell you two stories and i'm actually
going to lay a problem at your feed that
we need help with in the banking
industry um i am uh the proud uh
honor of leading this group
of the eighth largest payment
organization on the planet did you guys
know that
right
do any of you carry a barclay card at
all in your wallets
thank you very much by the way i bet a
lot yeah i bet a few of you do
we actually have three business lines
and each of those business lines have a
large presence across the the markets
that we operate in we have barcode card
us which we partner with the likes of
l.l bean u.s air
apple and others and we are the seventh
largest provider of mastercard visa in
the united states
in the uk we have in europe we have two
major business lines one's called
barclaycard europe we are the major
provider of uh credit cards in the uk as
a whole and in our other business which
is uh bbs market card business solutions
we actually process the majority of all
the acquiring systems across the uk and
pushing into europe acquiring for
example would be point of sale
commercial cards and such to give you
scale of that
two of our systems in the uk process 20
percent of the uk economy on a daily
basis we process 48 of all payments in
the united kingdom so that gives us a
very unique position on where we sit in
the payments ecosystem
now the way i'm going to start my
presentation about moving from social
monitoring to behavioral engagement we
have fallen into a situation in the
banking industry of how do we engage
with people going forward as folks move
more and more to social how does that
look folks aren't competing on products
where rates it's around how do i feel
when i use your product
our story starts about in 2010 in
november a few months before i joined
barclaycard we had a major incident
inside of the uk uh does anybody know
what sainsbury's is
it's sainsbury's is is the one of the
largest grocery uh
uh
companies inside the united kingdom um
on a beautiful weekend what happened is
we lost a network component called a pad
some of us probably don't even know what
those things are
and it took out all of the ability of
sainsbury to process
debit and credit cards regardless of
their bank
people were standing in line
with their shopping ready to go to do
their weekend activities
and they couldn't pay
they were only taking cash at that
moment what was really interesting about
this event
is
we did not know within barclaycard that
we had lost that network component and
that we'd lost the ability to acquire
for the grocery
and the grocery store across the country
didn't call their headquarters to say
they'd lost it they've said oh to be
back in a few minutes
as the second stick by uh people who are
shopping got agitated there were reports
of
shoving and also folks walking away from
their trolleys the first
word i learned when i joined barclaycard
a few months later is the word called
spoilage
what spoilage is is when you walk away
from a shopping trolley with food inside
of it you can't put it back inside the
freezers
so they lost sales opportunity they lost
product
and the first bullet in the war of
social uh engagement took place where
tesco the second largest
uh supermarket in the uk sent out social
media networks and they sent out print i
mean radio ads tesco's open come on and
join us
the first place that we saw the incident
showing up and it was by accident
people started posting on twitter
and we didn't know
so the reason i talk about that is that
led us to a place of what is our voice
of our customer how do we know what's
happening what is the customer journey
not only of the
large amount of merchants that we
support but of our customers that we sit
out there we roughly have 36 million
clients and customers around the globe
and
when you think about
before that november the only way we
interacted with you is you charged
something
you called us you paid us or you didn't
pay us
the majority of your interactions with
us were negative you never called us to
say hey thanks for a great job i made
that purchase that flat screen tv it's
why did i
get declined why is my statement wrong
so we had an idea of if people are going
to stand in line in a sainsburys and not
make a payment shouldn't we figure out a
way to see what was happening
out there and how are they going to do
it they're going to do this thing called
social media wouldn't it be cool right
at this point barclaycard had no mobile
apps in the market anywhere in the globe
we had some web presence around
and we never ever ever dealt in the
world of social media and what it meant
so a gentleman from uh capital one who
joined me over embarked a car by the
name of peter gott went away and said
hey we're going to figure out how to
monitor social media so that we can know
when incidents take place
what happened was is we didn't have a
lot of investment over the years of
network monitoring or application
monitoring tools so we figured if we
could use social monitoring to see what
the experience of the customers in the
wild would look like then we could
correlate that you saw a little bit from
the paypal guys earlier today correlated
to our system performance we could start
figuring out when an experience was
going bad if you notice i didn't talk
about a transaction i talked about an
experience
right
so we wanted to see from the moment
someone started interacting with us
whether it was through a merchant or
whether it's through one of our products
all the way through and back
and what we did is
we designed this based on a couple
different things we created some basic
algorithms and we looked at it and said
when a tweet or a facebook post we
started to get an instagram and tumblr
came through we rank it against a couple
different sophisticated algorithm
algorithms compared to what you guys do
we're using sledgehammers you're using
scalpels 100 right and what we what we
did though is a couple things that we
found it wasn't incidents that we were
discovering
it was people's customer journeys and
how they felt about them
some of the challenges that we really
ran into day one is and anthony
mentioned them is
what does it mean when someone posts
barclaycard is bad
barcode card is bad
it means two different things so all the
stuff that we had coming across
we didn't know how to parse it what did
it mean was it a good experience bad
experience
the difference between uk english and
american english you know the famous
saying you know uh you know two
civilizations separated by the same
language it's true
right
and so what we've been doing over time
is we've been parsing this through to
learn what does it mean to us and the
things that are keep jumping out at us
and we keep learning now here comes the
problem statement that i need folks to
help me with is
what is a good customer engagement
and what i mean by that is
when people post online they're posting
about
the experience they're having
what we want to start building is the
behavioral engagement of saying we want
you to interact with us more
right
and right now the only way you interact
with us is when we want your money or
you want our money so what we're trying
to do and devise using the insights that
we're getting from social media is
how do you want to use your payment i
mean
what do you guys use your your payment
uh device for these days
purchases right
would you like to use them to get better
recommendations of restaurants or where
you're located would you like to get a
cohort deal like you and a couple of
your friends get together and get better
pricing on your next dinner out or
tickets to a movie would you like the
experience through your payments
organization to be able to say you know
what we can help you
pick out what is the next vacation you
want to have based on your past
purchasing and people who look like you
purchasing i mean would that be helpful
would that be creepy
in a lot of instances people will think
that's kind of creepy some others are
like we don't know what that interaction
looks like
and that's why
this social monitoring piece brought
forward to us we weren't sure how to
stay relevant in the market
does that make sense
man
do you guys feel that your payments
provided your credit card company knows
who you are and what you want in your
daily work
your daily life
cool
so just to give you uh some scale of
what is happening if you take us back
from
2010 to now
we actually processed 400 4.7 billion
transactions we had no
uh social media interaction we had no
mobile apps
since that time period since that day in
november
we've actually moved uh most of our uh
well 45 of our population to digital
active right we've actually reduced our
paper statements by 35
and we have uh huge numbers of app
downloads now that sounds like a good
story you guys go that's incredible
the challenge with that is that's a
massive amount of data coming into us we
don't know how to process we don't know
what to do with right there's
interactions and behavioral engagements
in there that we would actually love to
start leveraging to make experience for
our customers and our clients better
but we're still trying to figure out
what does it mean
how do we do design those great
experiences and those great engagements
right
and fraud the big one for us right and
this is actually one of the best
engagements i think we have achieved
over the last four years and it was
actually a surprise to us
so being able to digitally close down
fraud alerts has actually been a godsend
to our customers
target hit most of us in the industry um
that was a very scary experience for
everybody in the payments industry
the ability for us to close those down
digitally so in the past we would call
you did you make this purchase did you
go to this place now what we can do is
we can send you a text we can say did
you just make this purchase and you can
text back to us and say yes that was me
or no that's not me and we can instantly
shut that down
what i'm hearing now from the industry
on some of my friends is that the home
depot breach that was just reported is
actually going to be bigger than target
that's terrifying because that now means
your personal data my personal data is
now out in the wild
and we have to figure out better ways to
engage with you to make sure that we
protect as this as those breaches become
more commonplace
so
the thing that i want to throw out to
the crowd right because this is the
thing that we need to solve for is how
do we look at the voice of the customer
going forward right how do we engage and
these are some of the problems that
we're we're trying to solve through the
data that's coming in right so call in
interaction with the uh call center
agents also there's something
interesting that my colleague died block
and i were talking about over the last
couple days hearing some of some of the
speeches that are taking place which is
around
blogs right there's a lot of blogs out
there about payment providers or banks
how do we start skimming that
information and correlating it with the
social experience that is taking place
that we're seeing coming in and how do
we start designing
around that how do we create products
for people that actually would benefit
with that data
we don't know we don't know what that is
the the other parts of it is
the social interactions network we have
500 000 mentions on social networks a
month
500 000 we use less than one percent of
those
right that's how much noise is out in
the environment that's how much that's
how much uh you know the uh the insights
inside of that data make no sense at all
a lot of them actually which is actually
a new thing that i learned was the
retweeting bots right we actually
thought we launched a great product
recently and what happened is it got
caught in the retweeting bot cycle and
we got posted a million times it was
outstanding right we were very proud of
ourselves until we found out it just
automated going through
the other thing that we're using uh uh
as we launched through this is with new
products so we recently launched a
product called uh payband in the uk
and what it is it's actually your credit
card on your wrist and you can go around
and wave and pay and tap right we're
using the social interactions that we're
learning about to help market it out
when we launch a product so we can say
hey this new product is out but it's not
just a notification of the product that
goes out to the market
what it is is that we're launching it
out and telling people how to use it
where to use it how to use it
and that is actually helping our
merchants out as well so it becomes a
symbiotic relationship in an ecosystem
that's been very helpful to us so we're
working through all these things and
we're learning new ways to use it
another interesting way that we're
learning to use uh data in the social
networks is including that in your
risk-based analysis right so we have the
the bureaus that we can get your risk
information then we can also see where
have you purchased why you've purchased
and who you've purchased with and we
start balancing that into the risk
profile
but again this is new territory and
we're learning about what does it mean
to us and how does it affect your
behavior and our products that we're
providing you going forward
so far so good
yeah
cool
so
as ooh is it gonna go is it gonna go
it doesn't go all right so where i want
to leave you is on as we're telling
about the problems that we've had and
what we're needing to solve and we've
learned a lot since we've been here one
of the the things that i want to tell
you is we have learned and we've learned
a lot and this is where it becomes very
important for us
back in
2012 and june of 2012 there was a major
incident in the uk financial system
there's a very well-known uh bank that
actually had a mainframe meltdown it was
so it was so prolific it actually has
its own wikipedia page by the way so i
have to tell you that's not a career
enhancer if you're an i.t person if you
actually get a wikipedia page because of
an incident
because we've been spending the last
couple years building out the capability
of understanding what the social
interactions look like and how they
affect our customers in their customer
journey
one of the things we found was we knew
that this particular institution was
having a problem
before they announced it to the industry
the problem was so bad and so prolific
for over several days that the
regulating body in the uk called the fca
actually sent a letter out to all the
banks saying you have to guarantee this
this wouldn't happen to you they didn't
notify anybody they're having an
incident for about a day and a half
right
we actually saw the incident as soon as
it was taking place because we actually
saw people going to twitter saying that
they couldn't pull money out of a bank
their credit cards weren't working their
mortgages were bouncing and their
paychecks weren't getting deposit we
were instantly able to look at that and
correlate it to our system performance
and the first question i was asked the
morning that we saw these events taking
place was what's happening because some
people
believe that the uk
payments and banking system was under
attack
absolutely true story what happened is
because we were able to look at the
social monitoring we could see who those
customers were and we could look at our
platforms in operation we were able to
go back and say it's not us it's this
institution and then we were able to
build a ring fence around ourselves
to ensure that we would withstand the
next couple days as the
financial sector was recovering itself
it was so bad that i'll put it this way
it affected our customers it also
affected our colleagues so if you were
getting if you were a barclaycard
employee
and you banked with this particular
institution your paycheck wasn't being
deposited so it allowed us to jump into
a position to make sure that we could
take care of our our employees and make
sure that they had money to pay their
mortgages a large amount of mortgages
were bouncing so we were able to look at
those of our customers that were our
customers and provide them some relief
so this insight
that we learned from our experience in
2010
to that day in 2011 allowed us to
predict what would take place what was
happening and insulate our population
from what was taking place at that point
but as i was saying earlier there's so
much data and it means so much we're not
sure what we're needing to do and we're
working through that as a process right
now
so i'm going to leave you guys with this
right
is that all the great things that we saw
over the last couple days
what i would say if you're looking for a
hard problem let me know because i have
a hard problem
i i it's definitely
and if you are working in this area the
place that really would be beneficial is
in the financial services sector as a
whole
the banks are at a point where we have a
uh crisis of who we are right coming out
of 2008 we thought we were one thing in
the sector we're now trying to redefine
ourselves and your guys help from a data
perspective of looking in and learning
and being able to help us design what
banking should be from a behavioral
engagement perspective going forward
is what we need